Oh
we welcome you to our second panel of
the day and before I begin that I
actually had someone come up to me and
say we never asked this question I don't
know much about Hillsdale College we
have a lot of faculty members this year
who have never attended one of our
events before and they're from colleges
of course all over the United States and
Canada Hillsdale College accepts no
federal or state tax money we're only a
very very energized group of people who
believe in the freedom that this country
has has and we want to protect it and we
are privately funded for everything we
do so that is Hillsdale in a nutshell
now the free market forum is as I said
last night an extension to all of these
faculty members and we love having the
state policy leaders here we work with
the Council for Christian colleges and
universities and the Acton Institute for
the Study of religion and liberty and
our panel chairman today is with the
Acton Institute Chris Morin Chris could
not be with us here last night because
he had an event in Texas and then he
flew in in the evening but we're so glad
he's here today and he's on our advisory
committee for this program Chris is
actually the co-founder and executive
director director of the Acton Institute
and he has worked with that organization
since 1990 the Acton Institute organises
seminars around the world for
seminarians representing many Christian
denominations it act it works to promote
understanding of the ethical dimensions
of the free market today the Acton
Institute employs over 30 people with an
annual budget of six and a half million
dollars Chris graduated with economics
and international relations degrees from
Johns Hopkins University and in his role
as executive director of the Acton
Institute he has traveled the world
lecturing and consulting in more than a
dozen
countries he serves on the boards of the
foundation for economic education the
donors capital fund and Excel charter
Academy
he and his wife Joanie have four
children they live in Grand Rapids
Michigan and are active in st. Thomas
the Apostle Church
now as panel chairman for Ken we shrink
the federal bureaucracy please welcome
Chris Maureen good morning and thank you
Anita and thank you to Hillsdale and the
Durrell foundation for helping to bring
us all here today for really what is a
critical national conversation and
giving us such a congenial atmosphere to
discuss it in now I'm not sure what to
make of the fact that this panel is the
only one framed around a question and a
subset of questions and indeed can we
shrink the federal bureaucracy and each
speaker will take on a particular
department in the federal government
with a similar question now I'm
sometimes accused of being a pessimist I
consider myself a realist but I am
hoping that the questions posed in this
panel are not purely rhetorical but some
cynicism is warranted for we'll be
dealing with the topic of can we
eliminate the Department of Energy
Education and Commerce and not
coincidentally these are three
departments that none other than the
Gipper
our beloved Ronald Reagan vowed to
abolish so it's fair to ask if Ronald
Reagan couldn't do it can it be done now
before introducing our panelists I want
to leave you on a hopeful note which is
in short supply today so far one year
ago in September there was an
astonishing announcement emanating from
the Capitol the president announced a
massive reduction in the size and scope
of government including wholesale
elimination of departments in the
federal bureaucracy
and the firing of nearly 25% of the
federal workforce what you didn't hear
about this actually it's absolutely true
sadly however I wasn't speaking about
our president or our country I was
citing Raul Castro of Cuba and this
brings me to my own paraphrasing of
today's panel if Cuba can do it can we
and lest you think Castro's charge was
purely rhetorical I point you to the
latest announcement really just two
weeks ago from Cuba Castro announced the
elimination of the Department of sugar
now really this is the symbolic and
historically practical equivalent of
limiting the government oil ministries
of any of the oil producers in the
Middle East
it really is hopeful okay so on that
hopeful note let me introduce our
panelists and dealing with the first
really controversial question of this
panel do we need the Department of
Education they have none other than dr.
charles murray well-known political
science author and libertarian now he
first came to national attention in 1984
with the publication of losing ground
American Social Policy from 1950 to 1980
which has been fairly credited as the
intellectual foundation of the welfare
reform Act of 1996 and I might say on a
personal note I was at university in the
middle 80s and I became a libertarian
and about 86 and your book was one of
the very first books I read and had a
powerful formative influence on my life
and if you haven't read losing ground
it's as relevant today as it was a 1984
and I commend it to your attention his
1994 book and bestseller on the New York
Times list was the bell curve which
sparked a heated controversy for its
analysis of the role of IQ and a sharing
in in shaping America's class structure
his latest book
real education for simple truths for
bringing America's schools back to
reality provides a framework for
rethinking about what parents should
demand of the educational system dr.
Murray has earned a BA in history at
Harvard and holds a PhD in political
science from MIT
now following dr. Murray will be
addressing the additional vexing
question of is the Department of Energy
worth the money helping us to dissect
that is Jerry Taylor Jerry Taylor is an
acknowledged expert on energy
environmental policy he's a columnist at
Forbes and a frequent contributor to The
Wall Street Journal and National Review
he's written for The Washington Post New
York Times Los Angeles Times among
others as a regular host on CNBC and
Bloomberg radio Taylor directs the Cato
Institute's work on energy and
environmental issues he has served on
several congressional advisory bodies
and has testified frequently on Capitol
Hill on these matters and finally we
will hear from Ian Murray on the
question abolish the Commerce Department
and actually I'm seeing his first slide
and there's no question mark there's an
exclamation point so I'm sorry too sorry
to ruin the suspense for the rest of you
here Ian Murray is a vice president for
strategy at the Competitive Enterprise
Institute
better known as CEI he's the author of a
best-selling book on environmental
policy entitled the really inconvenient
truths and most recently stealin you
blind how government fat cats are
getting rich off of you he specializes
in energy environment finance trade and
Science and Technology issues originally
from the UK mr. Murray emigrated to the
u.s. in 1997 after having worked in a
bureaucracy advising ministers on
railroad privatization and the role of
private finance in infrastructure reform
so you were one of the good guys there I
guess mr. Murray holds a BA and an MA
from Oxford and an MBA from the
University of London please join me in
welcoming
entire panelists here document thank you
very much I just want to begin by saying
I think it's appropriate to talk about
getting rid of whole departments because
there's a kind of bridge we have to get
over I think in the political dialogue
if we talk about cutting the bureaucracy
by five or 10 percent first it's not
going to happen and secondly it misses
the point it's not that the
bureaucracies are over staffed it is
that they are in in many cases entirely
useless and we can get rid of them
altogether and and this is not said from
a strict libertarian viewpoint I think
we need to appeal to the American people
by saying look you don't have to be a
libertarian to agree we can get along
without this and let me use the
Department of Education as an example
there could be three legs on which we
say that the Department of Education is
justified one would be its
constitutional appropriateness the other
would be that there are problems with
education that can only be solved at the
federal level and the third is the track
record of the Department of Education
and of federal educational efforts since
the 1960s so let me take each of those
in turn constitutional appropriateness I
am talking to one of the few audiences
that I we could assemble who I think
mostly agree with me on this at the time
of the Constitution it wasn't just that
that education was not considered
something the federal government should
do it wasn't really considered something
that government needed to do at all at
any level but the shakiness of the
Department of Education is
constitutionality goes far beyond that
there's simply nothing in the
Constitution that says that this is
something of that the Congress has the
right to legislate on except of course
the Commerce Clause there is no
plausible rationale for using the
Commerce Clause to justify federal
intervention and education
I'm sure the Supreme Court has found a
rationale I said there is no plausible
rationale for it on a broader level the
American founders had an allegiance to
the idea of it's basically the Catholic
principle of subsidiarity that things
should devolve to the lowest possible
level at which they can be done and
education is one of those things that
parents can do and and individuals
acting cooperatively together let alone
something that the government has to do
I would be in favor of abolishing the
Department of Education purely on on
these principle grounds even if it had
been effective but since those of us who
agree on that point are in a very small
minority in this country we have to deal
with pragmatic questions that brings us
to the second leg which is the existence
of serious problems that could only be
solved at the federal level the first
intervention major intervention of the
federal government in education actually
came in 1958 because of Sputnik and
there was at that time a fear as those
of you who were old enough to remember
will agree a real fear that we were
falling behind the Soviet Union in these
fields and one of the reasons was that
we didn't have nearly enough of our kids
going into science and technology and so
the federal government did try to
encourage that and and the the nature of
the motivation is reflected in the title
of the Act the National Defense
Education Act of 1958 but what really
and snared the federal government in
education was the civil rights movement
the Supreme Court had declared
segregation of the schools to be
unconstitutional in 1954 they did it for
the wrong reasons but it was the right
decision but except for a few highly
publicized cases like Little Rock and
james Meredith entering the University
of Mississippi
not a whole lot changed over the course
of the next decade was it necessary for
the federal government to act and I
think there is a rationale in this case
for saying yes constitutional rights of
large numbers of citizens were being
violated and one of the things that
the federal government can legitimately
do is enforce the constitutional rights
of its citizens but we saw a very
typical story that what would have
justified a one-time intervention to
ensure the ability of citizens to to
enjoy their constitutional rights turned
into a continuing involvement in
education at a broader level and the
reason that happened once again has to
do with the civil rights movement and
minorities at about the same time that
the fight over desegregation was going
on
you also had increasing attention being
given to the disparities between black
and white educational achievement black
and white test scores and so forth and
it was in the spirit of the times that
there would be a strong impulse to do
something about that and there was
nothing wrong with the impulse to do
something about that but unfortunately
because of the temper of the times and
the coming to power of Lyndon Johnson
who was a massive legislature
legislature and with a massive
legislative majority in 1964 65 66 we
got the education Elementary and
Secondary Education Act of 1965 and the
Higher Education Act of 1965 and the
federal government was in the education
business big time and that then brings
us to the third leg they've been in the
education business big time now since
about 1965 what does that track record
look like well the easiest way to answer
that question is through an actually
quite good test that is given by the
Department of Education actually the
National Center for Educational
statistics performs a useful function I
will grant that and a number of other
things they do the National Assessment
of Educational Progress called the NAEP
and they administer it to fourth eighth
and twelfth graders periodically and we
have consistent data over the last
thirty years since the 1970s
1970s on math and reading what's
happened well there's some good news you
can see the the actual trend lines on
this by the way in the paper on which my
presentation is based it will be posted
on on a website that you'll be told
about but but the short story is this
among the fourth graders you can point
to about a point two standard deviation
improvement in the scores how big is
point two standard deviations on an IQ
test that would be three points
difference you know when the mean is a
hundred not a whole lot in height let's
say the height of women a two point two
standard deviation difference is half an
inch it's not a big increase but it is
an increase unfortunately that was for
fourth graders when you get up to eighth
graders and twelfth graders that
diminishes same thing with reading only
worse in reading when you you have them
small gains among fourth graders twelfth
graders reading scores are absolutely
flat and it gets still worse than that
because it starts these these trend
lines start in the late 1970s which was
at the absolute bottom of American
education you may know this because you
watched SAT scores going down during the
night last half of the 1960s in the
1970s or for that matter you may have
had children in school at that point and
know that the schools basically became
utterly dysfunctional during that period
even more so than they are now
but when we talk about what the the
trend line has been we're saying it's
been fairly flat even though we know we
were at the bottom at that period then
the question becomes well was there any
reason to think that education wasn't
getting better before the federal
government got involved and for that we
have a very interesting and unique
database that hardly anybody but me
knows about it and one of the reasons I
know about it is because
I grew up in Iowa where they gave
everybody in Iowa the Iowa Test of Basic
Skills and they started doing that in
1942 and continued doing that until the
1990s and it wasn't a sample of kids who
got this test everybody in the state did
now if you're trying to interpret what's
going on in American education
what good is it to look at the single
state of Iowa well if you're interested
in minority education it's not very
helpful because up through about 1970
Iowa was 97 percent non Latino white
even now it's 91 percent non Latino
white but if you're asking about
actually an uncomplicated trend line a
trend line that's not confused by
changing proportions of ethnic groups
and so forth it's really a very strong
database and guess what from 1942 to
about 1967 the test scores of the
composite score for ninth graders
I choose ninth graders because there was
a big change in the percentage of kids
who went all the way through high school
during that period so ninth grade is a
better measure for among ninth graders
scores during that period went up by
almost a full standard deviation now
we're not talking in something trivial
we were talking on an IQ test we're
talking the difference between an IQ of
a hundred not an IQ of 115 which is a
big deal so you had major improvements
going on throughout the 1950s when the
government wasn't doing anything federal
government wasn't and from what we know
from other data in other states which
don't go back as far they aren't as
complete but pretty much the same story
education was improving throughout the
United States until about the mid 1960s
when the federal government got involved
it's just too good to be true for people
like us who tend to believe in free
markets and the government isn't
effective but that's what happened I
won't try to make the causal case okay I
don't think because we passed the
Education Act of 1965 that particularly
triggered the downturn there are lots of
other culprits including
ascendancy of progressive education at
about that time but the basic story is
this we didn't need to get the federal
government involved in education in
order to improve the quality of
education for our kids by all of the
longitudinal data that we have available
to us okay so you can then turn to to a
more focused question federal government
got involved in large part to help the
disadvantaged and especially minorities
to do better by giving money
specifically to school systems that had
large proportions of disadvantaged and
minority kids that was the whole point
of the title one maybe we improve their
education well the people who passed the
bill genuinely believed we would and so
from the very beginning the title famous
title one of the education and secondary
Elementary and Secondary Education Act
had lots of evaluations that were
conducted in the 1960s in the 1970s in
the 1980s in the 1990s they have been
evaluating that thing over and over and
over again those evaluations have
largely been conducted by people who
desperately wanted to find good news
okay and they couldn't repeatedly there
has been a failure to find any credible
evidence that the efforts of the
Elementary and Secondary Education Act
of 1965 had produced a significant
positive impact on student achievement
it's once again it gets even worse than
that if you step back from the formal
evaluations and look at the test score
gap on the NAEP between high poverty
schools ones with lots of kids living
below the poverty line and low poverty
schools the results are published in
2001 that this great gap grew rather
than diminished from the earliest years
such comparisons have been made 1986
through 2019 99 that brings us to No
Child Left Behind any of you remember No
Child Left Behind
nobody talks about it anymore it was the
law that are legislated that by the year
2014 all the children would be above
average I am I'm dead serious when I say
that they said that all children would
be proficient well the percentage of
children who were proficient was such
that you know harder for everybody to be
proficient they would all have to become
above average by the standard that
existed when the law was passed nobody
talks about anymore it failed utterly it
failed utterly for reasons that could
have been predicted at the time it was
passed and some of us did predict it but
it's gone in summary the long intrusive
role of the federal government in k-12
education doesn't have any credible
evidence I would argue for a positive
effect on American elementary and
secondary education okay I will spend
just a few brief minutes on higher
education and since we have a number of
faculty members in the audience perhaps
I will encounter some opposition to what
I'm about to say but let's go ahead and
do it there's much less agreement on
first principles when it comes to
college education most of us I think are
working from the same principles in
terms of k-12 education but I have a
take on what's been going on with
college education that maybe not
everyone will share namely that the BA
as it has evolved over the last
half-century has become the work of the
devil
it is now a substantively meaningless
piece of paper and I mean that literally
meaningless if you don't know where the
degree was granted and what courses were
taken it's really expensive I look
around the parents and grandparents in
this room we all know how expensive it
is about seven thousand dollars per year
in tuition not including transportation
food housing so forth for public
universities and an average of about
twenty-seven thousand a year for private
universities and yet this meaningless
piece of paper has become the
requirement
for getting a job interview for millions
of jobs because it's a cost-free way for
employers to employ a you know rough
screen for a certain amount of IQ and a
certain amount of perseverance if you
manage to get the BA so what happens if
you have something that's a minimum
requirement for getting the job
interview but it's also true empirically
true employers don't pay too much
attention about grade point average in
that they just want to know if you add
the BA well what happens then is that
you establish a paper credential that
that the kids really want to get but you
can get that paper credential by taking
the easiest possible courses and doing
the least possible work
the result is you have hundreds of
thousands at least of students who are
attending college and not to get an
education but because of a rational
desire to get that piece of paper when
the Dean of one East Coast college that
I'm familiar with is asked how many
students are in his institution he likes
to answer oh six or seven
unfortunately what he is saying is is
too often true this is not based on
horror stories about silly courses that
we all know exist in the college
catalogs and stories about the trivial
study requirements you can get a BA
these days without ever writing a term
paper in many universities and that it's
not about the stories about campus binge
drinking it's thoroughly documented a
number of very good books and that this
kind of thing affects a large proportion
of the kids going to college the
Department of Education is not only
implicated in this evolution it has been
the enabler through the huge loan
programs and the huge grant programs
that that its funds which total about
one hundred twenty five billion dollars
in 2010 for loans and thirty two billion
dollars in grants absent this level of
intervention it seems to me quite
obvious
that over the last three decades we have
would have seen a much healthier
evolution of post-secondary education
that focused on concrete job credentials
and courses of study that are not
constricted by this idiotic four years
at a residential institution that we
have now and the absence of this
artificial intervention also would have
led to a lot of market forces that held
down costs defenders of the Department
of Education can unquestionably make the
case that they have increased the number
of people going to four-year residential
colleges I view that as part of the
department of education x' indictment
not its defense well what other case
bite might be made for federal
involvement in education contributions
to good educational practice what has
been the positive developments in
education in the last 20 30 years
homeschooling and charter schools and
the government had absolutely zero to do
with either one of those except getting
in the way of what parents were trying
to do to improve the education of their
children if you talked about the
important books that have been written
or developments improving curriculum and
the rest of it you think of people who
have done these things who in in
universities you think people like Edie
her shoes developed a wonderful core
knowledge curriculum after he published
his landmark book cultural literacy back
in the 1980s
this isn't government stuff that the
government spends 200 million dollars a
year funding contracts to improve
educational practice you cannot point to
any as far as I'm concerned that
demonstrate an effect so I understand
that if the Department of Education
disappeared tomorrow it would cause
great problems because a lot of schools
have become dependent on federal money
and so there would be a lot of
readjustments that would have to be made
in terms of where the money comes from
and how budgets are handled that much I
will grant you but if you ask what would
happen if the Department of Education
disappeared tomorrow in terms of the
quality of American education the answer
that question seems to me unambiguously
no thank you
good morning my topic is whether the
Department of Energy is worth the money
and it reminded me of a story that I had
heard recently about a woman who went
into a bar and she sat down next to a
relatively attractive man in the fellow
turn to the bartender says I'll have one
of your specials and she turned to the
man and said well what's so special
about it well he had a drink and he got
up off his stool and he just started
flying around the bar and the woman says
my gosh I'll have one of those too she
got a special she climbed up on the bar
dov'è off broke her arm cut a few teeth
bartender turned to the guy and says
Superman you're a real jerk when you get
all liquored up like that so what does
that have to do with the Department of
Energy precious nothing but I figure if
you're going to persevere through 20
minutes of agony on the Department of
Energy I'd at least started out with a
joke the do-e was formed back in 1977
there were four reasons listed for the
rashes or the need for this department
one was to address the shortage of
non-renewable energy the second was to
address the dependence on foreign energy
the third was the need for a strong
national energy program and the fourth
was the need to centralize and better
manage all the disparate agencies than
the federal government so in the course
of answering the question is the
Department of Energy worth the money
what I'm going to do is ask the question
whether the Department of Energy has
been successful in addressing the
non-renewable energy shortages that
allegedly haunt us or our dependence on
foreign energy is the deal we the best
means to address those two matters and
other stated goals or concerns of the
deal we worth worrying about in the
first place it probably won't surprise
you at all to hear right up front that
my conclusions are no no and no first of
all let's look at the in Creole edged
increasing shortage of non-renewable
energy as the deal we succeeded in
reducing scarcity no if you look at the
data the best metric on scarcity is
prices something's becoming more scarce
that's going to become more expensive
that's the best means by which we can
measure whether something's becoming
more abundant or more scarce well the
weighted average of fossil fuel prices
since 1977 on our per BTU basis has
actually doubled so the Department of
Energy has not done a very good job
alleviating the shortage of non-renewal
energy in fact non-renewable energy has
become far more scarce today than it was
when the department was founded now is
the deal we the best means of addressing
this scare this alleged scarcity not
really the deal we can only address
scarcity by subsidizing research and
development for fossil fuels and
non-fossil fuel substitutes and by
promoting energy efficiency standards
that's how the deal we try to address
this problem you might say well the
federal government could increase
drilling on federal lands and yes it can
but that's the Department of Interior
that's not the Department of Energy so
as far as reduce trying to increase
supply through R&D what's the track
record well as we've seen Energy's
becoming more scarce not more abundant
so it's not very good but the R&D
literature itself is very dense and
conflicting without getting bogged down
in it we can say however a couple of
things with some certainty first the
deal we escaped demonstration programs
and big-budget R&D projects have been
miserable failures think fusion thinks
synthetic fuels lately Solyndra is
another example of an ongoing multi
decade boondoggle for wind and solar
energy DOA has produced nothing of
consequence in their big budget projects
the alleged do-e success stories that
are trotted out by proponents are very
poorly documented anecdotes the
governmental Accountability Office did
an analysis of the 50 leading success
stories trotted out by the department
for how wonderful their R&D has been and
they concluded it was so riddled with
mathematical errors logical leaps and
all sorts of problems in the analysis
that it wasn't worth the paper was
written on and that was the GAO s
conclusion third we find there's no
correlation at all between publicly
funded energy R&D and improvements in
energy efficiency or reductions in the
carbon intensity at the energy sector it
doesn't matter how much we spend on R&D
things don't seem to improve on those
scores moreover there's no correlation
between energy efficiency standards by
in fact and improvements in energy
efficiency in the economy if you look at
data regarding the amount of energy
necessary to produce ene GDP you'll find
that over time it improves at a very
steady pace it doesn't matter how much
we're spending on R&D at the federal or
state level it doesn't even matter where
energy prices are there are very steady
constant gains and energy efficiency
that seem completely invulnerable to
public policy stimuli
so is the BOE the best means to address
these shortages I would say no the best
means to increase the supply of
non-renewable energy is the course lower
taxes on private production and to
facilitate the production of
non-renewable energy on federal lands
the IRS can do the form of the
Department of Interior can do the latter
there's no room for the deal we here the
best means to reduce demand for non
renewable energy if that's something we
want the government to do is the tax the
heck out a non-renewable energy and of
course that's something that the deal we
wouldn't do that's something the IRS
would do the best means to address
market failures and research and
development is to make all R&D somewhat
more attractive to private investors if
you look at the literature and you read
the accounts for economists for why the
government needs to be involved in R&D
detail a very straightforward story
people who invest in R&D in come up with
successful innovations or technologies
can't fully capture the benefits of what
they've created other people going to
capture some of those benefits and so
private actors are going to invest
sub-optimally in R&D all right if that
bothers you if you think that's a
significant enough problem then the
correct remedy is to make all investment
in R&D somewhat more attractive maybe by
refundable R&D tax credit or something
the kind the criticism is not that
people the private sector too stupid to
know what to invest in it's not that
they can't read accounting sheets it's
not that they are blind to certain kinds
of R&D projects it's that they have a
general lack of incentive to invest
optimally that would be the correct way
to address this market failure not
through targeted R&D programs subject to
political decision making and all the
other public choice problems we find
when the government gets involved in
things so if scarcity all that having
been said worth worrying about in the
first place however again probably not
the market does not fail to respond to
scarcity price signals addressed very
rapidly to change as a supply and demand
and they were just robustly and
consumers respond efficiently the
complaints by the consumer advocates are
not believe me that the price mechanisms
don't work very well when scarcity
occurs they work very very well which is
why prices can in oil and gas and
electricity can move greatly and also
affect consumer behavior very greatly
that's why people scream and ask for
government to protect them from these
price signals the market doesn't fail to
address scarcity and although fossil
fuel prices have increased since 1977 as
I mentioned it's really unclear
there's any long-term trend here that
suggests really physical scarcity is in
play
for instance let's look at let's look at
each of the non-renewables in turn first
when it comes to oil prices professor
James Hamilton au California San Diego
undertook a very interesting
investigation where he examined
quarterly oil price data from the first
quarter of 1970 through the first
quarter of 2008 and here's what he found
although prices increased by one hundred
and seventy two percent over the sample
period or an average of one point one
two percent per quarter Hamilton could
not reject the null hypothesis that
there was no trend at all in this data
secondly the debt the data is most
consistent with the observation that oil
prices move akin to quote a random walk
without drift and third the best
predictor of future price according to
Hamilton is present price so given those
conclusions it's not altogether clear
that oil is increasingly scarce let's
look at natural gas hydraulic fracking
has radically altered the picture in
natural gas markets and expectations
about future supply futures markets
point towards very stable natural gas
prices over the next nine years and
commodity price forecasters expect gas
to increase only modestly in price
through 2021 we certainly do not face
the kind of scarcities in natural gas
that many people believe and when it
comes to coal well the very abundance of
coal is why environmentalists are
worried about climate change we're not
running short of coal so it's not
entirely clear to me there is a problem
to be to be addressed and even if there
were markets can respond very well to
changes the supply and demand what about
the dependence on foreign energy as the
deal we succeeded here once again no in
1977 47 percent of the energy we
consumed in this country came from
foreign suppliers in 2009 that figure
stood at 52 percent so the Department of
Energy failed to do much here now one
might argue in fact if you're paid by
the Obama administration you would argue
that the markets fear for imported
energy would be even greater we're at
naught for the wonderful do-e but that's
difficult to believe the primary energy
import of consequence here is crude oil
we don't report much natural gas or coal
crude oil is important because it's
cheaper at the margins of producing
crude from domestic suppliers them buy
from from a buying crew from domestic
suppliers and do a is done absolutely
nothing to reduce the cost
domestic crude oil production and in
fact there's very little it could do in
that regard anyway if the is the deal we
the best means to address oil dependence
know the most direct and efficient
answer as far as oil dependence is
concerned if we want to address it is to
tax oil imports very direct and a very
effective manner the heavier the tax the
more will reduce our dependence on
foreign oil reducing dependence on
foreign oil however I should note is in
direct opposition the goal of leaving
the shortage of non-renewable energy if
we're going to restrict imports in this
country we are by definition going to
restrict supply we're going to make it
more scarce this is another example
where government is both hitting the
accelerator and hitting the brake at the
same time but should we worry about our
reliance on foreign oil I know many of
you in the audience probably think we
should I think you're wrong I don't
think this is worth wasting any sleep on
over at all first of all we hear that
our reliance on foreign oil means that
we need to trade blood for oil that we
need to defend these or regimes in the
Middle East because they're vital
suppliers and it leads us into war well
the problem here is that oil producers
will certainly pay for their own
security needs as long as doing so
results in greater profits than
equivalent investments in some other
thing given the fact that oil producers
only have oil to sell on the market it's
for the most part their most valuable
commodity
without their economies fall apart the
idea if the United States weren't
defending oil produced production
facilities pipelines or shipping lanes
that nobody would is silly people of
course would the idea that the Saudis or
other oil producers can't defend their
oil infrastructure is likewise silly the
Saudis other Middle Eastern governments
paid for fifty five percent of the first
Gulf War they certainly have the money
to spend if they want to spend it the
best way to look at our involvement the
Middle East to protect foreign oil
producers as a gift there's a welfare
project for producers abroad you might
support or oppose that welfare project
but it's certainly not a necessary
welfare project others argue well maybe
we don't to defend it but we have to
kiss their rings I was on a I was on
Chris Matthews show and he says but you
know isn't this reliance on foreign oil
means we have to go bow down and kiss
the rings of the Saudis to get their
crude well no friendly relations with
oil producers and either enhance access
to import a crude oil nor lower its
price oil producers or profit maximize
there's . . and in the story they are
interested in the dollar notice that
hugo chavez's happy to sell us all the
crude we will buy we and the former
friends we had in Iran and the Shah was
one of the biggest price hawks
in the OPEC nation in the OPEC world
making friends with producers doesn't
change their calculation at all this
isn't just my casual observance of this
if you picked up one of the best books
on the subject it's more EA tomans book
genie out of the bottle world oil since
1970
Adelman was once the it still is
probably the most prominent oil
economist of the world he argued quote
we look in vain for an example of a
government that deliberately avoids a
higher income the self-serving
declaration of an interested party is
not evidence
moreover oil independence is pointless
you need to think I'm wrong about this
if even if all of our oil came from
Texas and Alaska a supply disruption
abroad whether it's because a plane cut
back or a terrorist attack or something
like that is going to increase the price
of crude oil everywhere no matter it's
where it's produced a great example this
is Great Britain until recently Great
Britain was energy independent got all
the oil it needed from the North Sea but
the supply disruption in 1978 when the
Shah of Iran fell had as big an impact
in Great Britain as it did in the in
Japan which was entirely dependent on
foreign crude so the idea that oil
independence getting all of our supplies
from domestic sources protects us from
international oil shocks is the
gibberish of a crazy man
what about embargoes embargoes to our
complete phantasms in 1973 didn't the
Arab oil embargo all that occurred is a
set of buying oil from air members of
OPEC we bought oil from people who
bought oil from Arab members of OPEC or
played a game of musical chairs in which
we bought from non-opec producers we
displace their old clients their old
clients then went to OPEC producers
there was absolutely no reduction in oil
imports in 1973 at all the main reason
for this is that oil is a fungible
commodity once oil is produced and put
on the market the producer doesn't
decide where it goes middlemen decide
where it go goes right it's the same
reason why in 1979 those of you who are
old enough to remember this remember
that the Jimmy Carter imposed a grain
embargo on the Soviet Union for their
invasion of Afghanistan it wasn't more
than a month until the newspapers were
full of stories about how US grain was
still finding its way into the Soviet
Union how was that when she was grains
on the market it's not up to President
Carter where
goes where the market wants to put it
and it ended up in the Soviet Union
so embargo is a complete phantasms we
don't have to worry about them at all
so where does all this leave us well do
we then need a comprehensive national
energy strategy Republicans tell us this
all the time their big complaint is that
the president isn't intervening
aggressively enough in energy markets to
suit their tastes well to what end what
exactly is the market failure in entered
in the energy sector that demands such
micromanagement well there's no scarcity
problem as we discussed that needs to be
addressed reliance on foreign oil is not
a problem that needs to be addressed and
when the US government couldn't do much
to address anyway there's just simply no
market failure here that is particularly
interesting only one jumps out at me
which is the environmental externalities
associated with energy consumption the
the argument here is that since the
consumer doesn't pay for all of the
environmental damages that are
associated with his energy consumption
his or her energy consumption prices are
too low and over end over consumption
results now this is a debatable point
but let's let's posit that it's correct
for the sake of this conversation what's
the correct remedy for that market
failure well it certainly isn't a
Department of Energy to promote all
kinds of research and development which
hasn't panned out anyway the most direct
way to address this if we want to
address it is to tax pollution now the
reason we don't tax pollution of course
that's a very transparent cost consumers
don't like to pay and so what we do is
we regulate emissions instead the idea
with regulation is to try to approximate
a world that would exist if polluters
had to pay the polluted for the damages
that they caused or for the rights to
continue polluting and the result would
be a certain level of emissions
regulation attempts to get us there
so if we have an issue with the
unintentional ease in the environmental
realm and we don't have the in the
political courage to actually tax the
emissions that we're worried about
directly we can increase regulations
indirectly notice this is a job for the
EPA not the Department of Energy we
might also concern ourselves a bit with
with uncompetitive nature of certain
energy markets it used to be we worried
about the big oil companies and the
Seven Sisters and how they controlled
the world oil market and in 1967 and 68
those argue
had some had some legs today big oil as
we know it which are the privately owned
integrated oil companies like Exxon BP
Shell and others constitute all of about
eight or nine percent of the world crude
oil market that's their market share the
market share of the crude oil of crude
oil market of today is largely dominated
by foreign federal by foreign ly foreign
owned oil companies like Saudi Aramco
and Al and others so the idea that we
need to worry about the uncompetitive
nature of oil markets again is the if
the Jew brings of somebody who's been
Saira genetically frozen since 1967 the
world doesn't work that way anymore
electricity markets are arguably
uncompetitive in certain ways in fact
fact I think you make a fairly good case
that left to their own electricity
markets would lead to some sort of if
not natural monopolies then it would be
very difficult to find entry to compete
with some of them but notice this is a
state issue we have state regulatory
agencies to deal with that sort of thing
just for the record where the Cato
Institute we don't like that either but
the point is if you are worried about
that and you shouldn't be but if you are
you don't need a Department of Energy
for that activity either the conclusion
I want to leave with you is that energy
really is no different from any other
commodity in the marketplace there is no
BTU exception found of the arguments for
it in the wealth of nations we don't
need a Department of Energy any more
than we need a Department of textiles a
compartment of computer chips or a
compartment of Department of anything
else now the question that the panel of
course I was asked to address the
question of whether the money we spend
on the Department of Energy is worth the
money and of course I say no but the
broader question is can we get rid of
the Department of Energy told you
whether you know whether we should but
can we the problem we have here is that
consumers and voters demand those magic
drinks at the bar that will solve
problems for them see how I loop back to
that bad joke
and the highly paid speaker I really
know my craft
but the reality is is that the public
wants the government to do something
about really annoying massive shifts and
energy prices one of the reasons why
gasoline prices can go skyrocketing over
a minor's story like a strike in Nigeria
or a hurricane of the Gulf of Mexico or
any number of small stimuli consent
prices skyrocketing is because demand is
relatively inelastic in the short run
it's a little bit more elastic in the
long run but the fact is given the
demand is somewhat inelastic in the
short run it's no surprise to you as
people who all drive cars that it takes
a real big increase in gasoline prices
to get you drive to eat to get you to
drive less even just a little bit less
and that's the reason it takes massive
price increases to balance the market
after there's been even minor
interruptions in supply the volatility
and an elasticity demand in the
electricity sector is equally great and
equally problematic because of that
consumers run to the government and ask
for protection because they don't like
to get faced with these kinds of high
prices and producers of course do the
same thing right now of course we're
wearing a boom cycle where everyone's
complaining about high price but in the
mid-1980s producers were screaming about
low price in Don Ho del then the
Department the Secretary of the Interior
after he left the Reagan administration
wrote a book about the horrible collapse
of oil markets and how old Peck was
flooding the market with crude oil and
how we wanted federal laws to do that
the federal government had to protect
producers and give them subsidies
because it works the other way around as
well when demand drops even a little bit
prices are going to collapse in oil
markets and so producers look for
government protection so the question of
can we get rid of the Department of
Energy is really a question of can we
quit looking for the government to
produce magical solutions and to cater
to consumers and producers to protect
them against gyrations and energy
markets that are endogenous and natural
they're not examples a market failure
they just happen to be unpleasant I
would like to think that we can do this
but I wait to be convinced anyway thank
you for your time
good morning ladies and gentlemen I hope
you don't mind hearing from another
British accent today I cannot promise to
be as articulate as my old friend Daniel
Hannan but I hope I can bring you some
insights from across the pond in
addition to his Charles and Jerry have
told you on the white of abolishing the
departments they refer to I'm going to
concentrate primarily on the how so my
presentation will be a little bit
different but I will start with some
justification for the plan I'm about to
present you as if David Henderson's talk
this morning did not give his reason or
not the Department of Commerce's mission
statement is a charter for government
interference in markets it employs
47,000 people directly and spends about
nine billion dollars annually on its
mission and I quote to promote job
creation economic growth sustainable
development and improved standards of
living for all Americans by working in
partnership with businesses universities
communions communities and our nation's
workers what this means in practice is
that the department exists to reward
businesses for following its favoured
policies it provides bailouts handouts
and the spoils of redistribution in some
ways just as the Department of Labor as
the government arm of the labor unions
so the Department of Commerce is the
government arm of rent-seeking
businesses this alone should be reason
for advancing its elimination but let us
take the department at its word all of
the purposes of the department has laid
out in this mission statement job
creation economic growth improved
standards of living even sustainable
development are things that happen on
their own in the general functioning of
markets to imagine that a government
department can do better than markets
are providing all these benefits is to
fall prey to what Hayek called the fatal
conceit I know of no better expression
of the
people conceit than that coined by
Douglas Jay later despite being a
socialist Lord J the man who brought the
thinking of John Maynard Keynes into the
British Labour Party in 1937 he wrote
that in some cases the gentlemen in
Whitehall
that's the center of British
administration really does know better
what is good for people than the people
know themselves this sentence was a
foundation of the British planned
economy that governed the country from
1945 to 1979 and which led one of the
greatest nations on earth down a path to
where it became the sick man of Europe
it is indeed to Whitehall that I shall
turn for inspiration in assessing what
to do with the Department of Commerce
not however to the Whitehall of Douglas
J but to the Whitehall of Margaret
Thatcher fact redoubtable lady realized
just how much of a burden over
centralized government had become on her
nation and as Prime Minister she pushed
through a series of public sector
reforms that provide a model for
rethinking American government as an
example when I started working for the
British Department of Transport straight
out of university in 1989 it had some
14,000 employees so proportion of the
population was about the same size as
Commerce here by a variety of means and
reforms but at the time I left after
privatizing myself out of a job in 1996
mrs. T and her successor John Major had
reduced that number to a policy core
just 2000 even though the subsequent
Labour government has vastly increased
the size of government overall in the UK
through new programs agencies and
regulations that number has not changed
demonstrating the resiliency of these
reforms as I outline what I suggest we
should do with the Department of
Commerce I shall make reference to these
reforms throughout this speech where to
start well if the cabinet was a news
bureau with the Secretary of Treasury
the economics correspondent the
Secretary of State the foreign
correspondent and the secretary defence
the war correspondent the Secretary of
Commerce would be the weatherman
I mean this quite seriously because the
single biggest agency in commerce
outside of census sewers is the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
which houses the National Weather
Service NOAA soaks up about five billion
dollars of the department's eight
billion dollar budget NOAA is actually a
strange hybrid of NASA and the EPA and
like the EPA was born a president
nixon's Department Ulrika B organization
in 1917 Nixon said it was needed a quote
for better protection of life and
property of natural hazards for a better
understanding of the total environment
and for exploration and development
leading to the intelligences of our
marine resources now there today boasts
that it is a provider of environmental
information services a provider of
environmental stewardship services and a
leader in applied scientific research
again each of these is a function that
could be provided privately and which is
probably worse for being provided
publicly now there today consists of six
main offices the aforementioned National
Weather Service the National Ocean
service the office of Oceanic
Atmospheric Research the National
environments of satellite service the
National Marine fishery service and the
office of marine and aviation operations
together they form a colossal operation
that has become one of the main drivers
of the climate change industry and as
such has become harmful to the u.s.
Commonwealth indeed its mission to
understand and predict changes in the
Earth's environment and conserve and
manage coastal marine resources to meet
our nation's economic social and
environmental needs with its emphasis on
prediction and management seems designed
around the fatal conceit that is not to
say that NOAA as a whole is useless but
it's organization is such that it
corrupts the useful functions it needs
to be broken up so first I suggest that
the National Weather Service be broken
away from the department with a view to
eventual prioritization when I first
suggested the privatization of the
National Weather Service during
Hurricane Irene I was met with a barrage
of criticism such as I have never
previously encountered even in almost 10
years of dealing primarily with global
warming which as cherry knows is not a
nun controversial subject the
level of visceral hostility to the idea
of privatizing weather forecasts and
warnings that astonished me yet we live
every day with the weather forecasts and
warnings provided by local radio
stations and college campuses being
sourced not from the NWS but from
private companies such as AccuWeather
repeated studies have actually found
that the forecasts and warnings provided
by these private companies are more
accurate and reliable than those
provided by the NWS indeed those private
weather services are themselves as a
result of a gradual prioritization of
the government's weather functions in
the past the NWS has provided radio
bulletins and even written the weather
forecasts for local newspapers we do not
think it necessary for the NWS to do
that today and as I just mentioned this
privatization process has improved the
quality of the forecasts the most
frequent argument I heard against
privatization was at the NWS provides
the data that the private company is
used as if by suggesting privatisation I
was advocating the dismantlement of data
gathering services does the Advocate of
air traffic control privatization want
to abolish the air traffic control
system when I worked on the
privatization of British Rail did I want
to rip up the tracks of course not
the idea that privatizing the the NWS
would lead to the end of data gathering
is facile the goal of privatization is
to improve services not for the most
part to abolish them by making them more
responsive to change and innovation
while removing the burden of their
upkeep from taxpayers and placing it on
its customers in a sense the NWS is
currently a taxpayer subsidy to
AccuWeather The Weather Channel and
others so the best way to handle the
privatization of the NWS I believe is to
move it first to what the UK
privatizations call trading fund status
the NWS which has a valuable product
should charge for that product to cover
its costs with multiple competing radio
TV and print outlets demanding his
products nevermind the other interests
like companies such as Amazon that rely
on just-in-time delivery and have a keen
interest in the what the weather is
going to be like the charge for its
services would probably be small change
for these of
operations and no cost to the casual
consumer like you and I the taxpayer
would be better off by 1 billion dollars
a year once the services achieved
trading fund status the next step is
full privatization the service could be
privatized as a single enterprise or by
being broken up it could be sold to
existing companies like a key whether to
startups or management buyouts or sold
to shareholders as a single body by IPO
all these arrangements have proved
successful in multiple prioritizations
around the world the exact form of
privatization would be decided as a
result of the move to trading fund
status which would help identify clearly
where the profit and cost centers of the
operation lay privatizations generally
leave to significant increases in
investment and infrastructure spending
so the product that we all rely on would
surely be improved not least we might
have a more accurate idea of whether or
not we will need an umbrella when we
leave the house I should note here that
there will be little or no national
security implications the armed services
all have their own weather functions
what security issues there may remain
can be dealt with in the mood to trading
for the status there are some odd rules
that prevent for example private
operation of weather radar these are
almost certainly antiquated and can be
revised with appropriate consideration
given to defense and air traffic control
concerns finally there is the question
of what to do with organizations like
the National Hurricane Center that do
some very specialized and valuable
research such as flying aircraft into
hurricanes for these organizations I
suggest an alternative form of
privatization which was used for example
in the privatization of the building
research establishment and similar
scientific organizations in the UK the
bre was privatized as a charitable trust
rather than as a for-profit body and has
become since one of the world's leading
research led consultancies on innovation
risk and sustainability and business
worldwide i would suggest at certain
industries such as the insurance
industry you would have a keen interest
in the success of such a charitable body
and will become major hunters
the other main related weather-related
function of NOAA is the national
environmental satellite service this
operates several satellites and collects
data from military and civilian services
both to mess
International these civilian operators
satellites could easily be managed by
private entities I receive my TV service
from a satellite managed by a private
entity and could be privatized as a
company either owned by all the new
weather companies combined or as a
charitable trust the various data
centers provide an academic function and
are used by academics internationally it
would be more appropriately funded and
run by academic bodies and should
therefore be transfer to universities
the prestige of housing such bodies as
the national snow and ice data center
should be attractive enough to
universities to be able to secure
funding to run them the national ocean
service is largely a survey organization
its various survey functions could be
transferred to the u.s. Coast Guard and
the US Geological Survey which could be
renamed the u.s. survey organization or
something like that the National marine
sanctuaries and other oceanic resources
could and should be privatized by sale
similarly the management of Fisheries is
best left not to bureaucrats but to
fishermen who have a direct ownership
stake in the health of the fisheries
where fisheries have been genuinely
privatized such as in New Zealand with
the fishermen's property rights
guaranteed fish stocks have rebounded
along with the fishermen's profits so
much than the National Marine fishery
service they can organise the
privatization of the fisheries and bow
out gracefully the office of Oceanic and
Atmospheric Research provides the
theoretical silent science as opposed
the applied science of the National
Hurricane Center of the like it consists
mainly of seven research laboratories
where appropriate these should be merged
to merge with the Applied Science
versions and privatize two Charitable
Trusts so those who are skeptical that a
research laboratory could be privatized
I'd point you to the laboratory of the
government chemist in the UK on
privatization LGC as it is now called
had a turnover of 15 million British
pounds and a staff of 270 it now has a
turnover of 130 million pounds in a
staff of 1300 it has successfully
acquired several European laboratories
and is a world and is a world leader in
analytical chemistry like it or not the
environmental business is here to stay
because of consumer demand there is no
reason why and environmental
laboratories cannot be privatized the
office of marine and aviation operations
which revised the ships and planes used
by NOAA agencies should obviously be
broken up
and its assets reassigned during this
privatization process there will
doubtless be many residual functions
left over after this process these
functions can be transferred to the EPA
or NASA if they are still felt
appropriate and conscious and Congress
is unwilling to terminate them next up
is the Census Bureau
unlike NOAA the census has a genuine
constitutional role but dysfunctions are
today well in excess of its
constitutional requirements the Census
Bureau should really concentrate on its
mission of keeping track of the
headcount for congressional
apportionment and abandoned its
accumulated functions of asking more and
more intrusive questions which are
normally used to redistribute wealth
along Democratic lines or provide free
market research for the business I am
open to the idea of the Census Bureau
being merged with all the various Cystic
allegiances of the US government such as
a bureau of economic analysis also in
the Department of Commerce the Bureau of
Justice Statistics the National Center
for Education Statistics as Charles
mentioned and the Bureau of Labor
Statistics many of these provide
important indicators such as the murder
rate unemployment levels or inflation
indices that provide important
information that helped guide
appropriate policy such an agency would
probably provide good value for the
money to the taxpayer if managed
effectively at any event it would be a
low priority for privatization similarly
the present office has a valid
constitutional function albeit one that
I regard as ill-founded
it would be a prime candidate for
separation for the department and
re-establishment as a performance based
organization these are the American
equivalents of the factor ID next steps
executive agencies which sought to
establish the service delivery functions
of government on grounds that achieved
high levels of consumer service while
providing good value for money to the
taxpayer neither of which is a virtue of
traditional bureaucracy PB OS was such a
good idea that they were fiercely
resisted by the Washington establishment
as such only one had been set up since
the ERR announcement vice president ago
of all people the patent office would be
an excellent candidate for versus
restarting this experiment given its
massive backlog in clearing patent
applications the current head of the
USPTO is an IP lawyer not a manager
a PPO would have a genuine manager as
its head of course in the absence of a
Secretary of Commerce it would need to
be housed somewhere for budget purposes
I've suggested all PP o--'s be
transferred the executive office of the
president or there's the Office of
Management and Budget because that is
what they are there for managing budgets
effectively I also imagine that a tbo
PTO cheap on the accession would cover
its own costs quite quickly next up is a
National Institute of Science and
Technology those standards and
technology with a billion-dollar budget
in some ways the NIS T is one of the
older centralizing agencies there is
dating back to George Washington's
demands for standardized weights and
measures the Boy Wonder Herbert Hoover
ever the engineer used its predecessor
to standardize tool sizes across the
u.s. although his successors were less
effective when they try to impose the
metric system thank the Lord
again most of na ist is Research
Laboratories which can be privatized
along the lines described earlier where
necessary the privatized Laboratories
can retain statutory roles this is
common in the privatized Laboratories in
the UK and elsewhere and it is revealing
when you look at the list of delegates
to the Committees of the system
Internacional and the like most
countries representatives are academics
or even private individuals only in the
American C's days since the fall of the
Soviet Union are bureaucrats moving
swiftly on become to the international
trade administration for the most part
the ITA organizes trade junkets and
enforces and anti-dumping regulations
which are a form of protectionism it is
no wonder that particularly under the
Clinton administration the office of
Secretary of Commerce was sought after
by party fundraisers these functions
should simply be abolished by Congress
those functions that Congress is
unwilling or unable to do away with
probably most likely related to
international treaties should be
transferred to the US Trade
Representative abolishing this office
would save taxpayers half a billion
dollars a year the same fate should be
taught before the administrator the
department's permanent stimulus programs
the economic development agents
administration and the minority business
development administration the EDA
regularly wastes taxpayer money
promoting projects that no one in their
right mind would pursue like the cedar
rapid are the Iowa Convention Center
that it is backing
to the tune of 35 million dollars which
will lose 1.3 million dollars annually
according to the city's own estimate in
another case the EDA attracted a new
warehouse to Visalia California to
create 250 jobs the firm that took the
EDS two million dollar grant promptly
closed its warehouse in Brisbane
California shedding 313 jobs in the
process
the MBTA does the same sort of thing
except on racial grounds and so is EE
event should there be anything worth
saving from the deserved wreckage of
these offices and I doubt it those
functions can be transferred to the
Small Business Administration these
abolitions would save three hundred and
fifty seven million dollars finally the
department also houses its own very own
branch of the homeland security
apparatus the sinisterly named Bureau of
Industry and security which is charged
with for example using export controls
to prevent the spread of weapons of mass
destruction again such functions would
be better off housed in the US Trade
Representative or Department of Homeland
Security and finally there is a National
Telecommunications and Information
Administration which manages the federal
used severely electromagnetic spectrum
these functions could be easily
transferred to the General Services
Administration while other functions
such as auctioning spectrum could go
through the Department of Treasury or
OMB and others like the grants for
promoting children's educational
television should be simply abolished
this is a brief overview of how we could
accomplish the outright abolition of an
entire government apartment the process
of abolition should be overseen by the
Office of Management and Budget
as was foreseen in a bill to abolish the
Department passed by Congress in 1995
but vetoed by President Clinton yes
Congress has already abolished the
Department once
so with the right Congress and with the
right president it can be done there is
hope one final word the department's
palatial headquarters in Federal
Triangle would make a magnificent hotel
and it even has its own tourist
attraction in the basement the National
Aquarium that was privatized in 1982
thank you gentlemen for those very
insightful non gibbering presentations
and thank you too for standing on time
which allows us to go forward with some
questions so if you'd like to ask a
question please raise your hand
microphones will find you and tell us to
whom you are addressing your question I
see one on the far back question for
charles Murray you mentioned that
employers are only concerned with
whether a candidate has that piece of
paper and not particularly concerned
with what the student has learned but
what extent would you say that that
phenomenon has grown because of the
Supreme Court's disparate impact
jurisprudence which makes it almost a
crime or at least a very dangerous thing
to test people for knowledge and
abilities and skills and so on that
Supreme Court decision and you're quite
right it's it's it's really tough to
test people has been absolutely crucial
in creating the artificial value of the
BA there there ought to be the problem
is that the solution to the artificial
artificial 'ti the BA in my view is
certification rather than degrees so
that you if you want to go into a job in
business you shouldn't be locked into
being a business administration major
for four years you should be able to go
take the college-level courses that you
want to take to learn about marketing or
accounting or the rest of it and then be
able to take a test and it wouldn't have
to be just a paper and pencil test there
could be work products - you know I'm
not limiting to that a test that you
could take the employer to demonstrate
what you know I think that this kind of
thing has actually potential even
despite the Supreme Court's decision you
know we still have the CPA test
certified public accountant test which
is used we have
lots of other certification tests that
are used and as long as you can
demonstrate that these actually have
relevance to the job requirements I
don't want to over you can get away with
what we could get away with using those
tests you still have things you have to
worry about with racial disparate impact
but you can't get away with those so
point number one Supreme Court decision
incredibly problematic in in terms of
artificially inflating the importance of
the BA there are ways that that that
that people can use concrete credentials
much more meaningful than the BA despite
that Supreme Court decision right up
front here I asked a similar question to
this the one I'm ready to ask now three
years ago at this same meeting and it
relates to energy we along this row are
all Midwest farmers and where our farms
are we have coal under the ground we're
currently producing food ethanol and
biodiesel
we have windmills adjacent or
practically on our land not only
directly on any of our land but
threatening and what's the Oh energy
source coal coal under the ground now my
question is with policy going the way
that it is energy policy how much
control over our own property and own
resources are we going to have
immediately and over the long haul will
the government be intervening in such a
way that we no longer can even respond
to a market because the markets will be
totally controlled in those areas and we
may be forced to produce the coal as
opposed to one of the other resources
thank you I'll let Jerry take the first
stab at that well do bear in mind that
a couple of the energy sources that you
mentioned that are being produced in the
Midwest wind and ethanol are being
produced entirely because of massive
government subsidy absent those
subsidies they wouldn't be produced them
it was so the government can create
energy sources and it can strangle
energy sources when it comes to coal on
private lands there are environmental
regulations associated with mining but
those regulations are not so onerous
that are prevents mining operations in
either eastern Appalachia or in western
parts of the United States the reason
you don't see a lot of mining for coal
in the Midwest we're presently it
doesn't exist the economics just simply
aren't there
you do see mining in Ohio and Kentucky
another part of the Midwest for the
economics or favorable where the
deposits aren't favourable you're not
seeing it one of the reasons for that by
the way is the fact that with natural
gas prices as low as they are today
it's almost everything at the margins
being built as gas-fired generation
about ninety five or six percent of new
generating capacity built in this
country over the last fifteen or twenty
years has been gas fired not Coal Fired
not nuclear not renewable but gas gas
has a lot of advantages relative to coal
I won't get into them right now but
that's not entirely a phenomena
associated with government intervention
there are just a lot of good reasons why
the industry is moving towards gas at
the margin putting on a crisp you know
looking at a crystal ball and asking
what public policy will be down the road
will the government prevent energy
extraction on private lands in the
future well to the extent to which they
regulate that activity with costly of
standards it can of course price you
audible Markus's and well you can you
know mine on private land but if you
can't pay the regulatory costs given the
market to make a profitable that's not
going to happen my own sense of it is
that the public is far more concerned
about high energy prices than they are
in var about environmental consequences
of energy production I think we're going
to see that play out in the fracking
debate where you've got natural gas
deposits so my my sense of it is that in
the long haul the government even though
environmentalists may want to prompt the
government to restrict energy production
on private lands when it
- gasps or maybe cold down the road I
don't think they're going to succeed
very well at the end of the day I think
most voters would shoot their own
grandmother to get about 10 cents off
again on the gasoline all right this
gentleman in the front room in 1965
during the Johnson administration
remember Head Start was a great thing
that was going to save elementary school
do you know of any date or dr. Murray
that apps say after four years do the
people who weren't in Head Start have
any different from people who were in
Head Start it's a very expensive program
that starts has been evaluated Oh I mean
you you literally have shelves of
evaluations of Head Start and when you
have that many evaluations you have
people that look at the elephant from a
variety of different ways so let me make
a couple of comments one is I think it
is a fair characterization of the
literature to say that the average Head
Start program there is no evidence that
you have retained value from that at all
then you say well what about really good
head starts and here some of you may
have heard of a thing called Perry
preschool the reason some of you may
have heard of it is because it is one of
the only success stories out there and
guess what if you have a thousand
failures and one success story which one
gets on the CBS Evening News Perry
preschool was an extremely intensive
preschool program it was like Head Start
on steroids it was it was Head Start
with a staff ratio of highly trained
people you know like one per three
children I don't know what it was
extremely intensive something we
couldn't conceivably afford and there
are there is evidence that it provided
sustained positive impacts that lasted
into adulthood not transformative ones
we're not talking about disadvantaged
kids who went out and graduated from
Harvard
school we're talking about a crime rate
that is really high but not quite as
high as the crime rate of similar kids
who don't get that so here I think is
where we stand on this issue a massive
program like Head Start will have no
permanent effects on cognitive ability
will have no permanent effects on school
achievement nor on the likelihood of
unemployment it is possible that very
very intensive programs preschool
programs can have some of those effects
they are not programs that we can afford
to do so given that a set of
circumstances here's the way I look at
something like Head Start and now I'm
not talking as a libertarian I'm talking
as a parent and who is concerned about
other children if you have children who
are in extremely deprived environments
they're living in homes where the mother
doesn't talk to them where there is no
father
perhaps there's abuse perhaps there's
chaos if we have a way to provide some
hours during the day in which those
children are in a safe warm nurturing
environment I don't really care if
there's school achievement ten years
from now is improved we have done
something good for those children and I
as a taxpayer and a libertarian will say
if you are doing that if that's what the
money is being used for that I'm willing
to pay the taxes but then you get to the
core issue of that's not what most
headstart places are like and those are
not the children they're serving it's
like so many other things involved with
programs that appeal to us as
individuals because what they are trying
to do is really good and the problem is
that the best way to provide those is
not through a massive Head Start the
best way to provide those is through
churches through local organizations
through neighborhoods of parents and
communities and all of those things are
precisely the institutions that are
innervated by the programs like Head
Start that are trying to do good things
I have just put in a period of about a
minute and a half or two minutes
something that I've written entire books
on so you'll excuse it if I don't if I
haven't filled in all the bits and
pieces on that right here in the middle
I have a question on education and kua
from Sterling College in Kansas I was
educated I was born in raised in
Singapore but I'm a US citizen I got my
higher education in u.s. I think the
freedom that we enjoy here based on the
liberty of Christ I think is tremendous
and when we've free up this freedom I
think we can produce we produce the most
Nobel Prize laureate against any nation
we produce the most innovation against
any nation and we can produce people
like Steve Jobs
Mark Zuckerberg but at the same time we
can produce people like Jeffrey Skilling
of Enron and also Madoff so what kind of
a education a system of education which
you encourage to promote Nobel Prize
laureate Steve Jobs the kind of
independent thinking and not Jeffrey
Skilling of Madoff Steve Jobs
lasted precisely one semester at Reed
College what's that
I lost one semester of it at Reed
College so
I think that what produces the
innovation and the creativity ultimately
is the atmosphere in which if you have a
great idea you can go out and run with
it and and I think that it is that
atmosphere much more than any specifics
about our educational system which has
been the biggest thing the United States
had going for it if you come to the
United States you can you can invent an
electronic devices that don't ring what
other people are stupid
okay the goods were taken care of now so
I don't think the educational system
itself is the solution there but the way
I want to recast the educational
objectives of this country it goes as
follows right now what we do is we say
you either grow up to be a person with a
BA which doesn't give you a whole lot of
prestige these days but the other kind
of person is the person who's just a
high school graduate and it is correct
that in today's culture they are
perceived in many important ways as
second-class citizens absolutely
needlessly suppose we recast the whole
system of Education and its goals as
follows the purpose of education
education has succeeded if a child grows
to adulthood having discovered something
he or she loves to do and having learned
how to do it well that's the first
change you make you cast it in terms of
finding something you love to do because
I am willing to bet among the people in
this audience those of you who have been
happy in your jobs it's because you love
it not because you made so much money at
it and it's been really important to you
and those who have not loved your job
see that as a major loss of your life
just that's first step the second thing
you want to do is to get rid of this
artificial division whereby somehow
being a lawyer is more fun than being a
cabinetmaker more fulfilling more
important it's that all of our careers
whether you we are history professors or
cabinetmakers or whatever we do we go
through a couple of phases we all start
out as apprentices and we all know that
we didn't stop being apprentices when we
got our college degree that's when our
apprenticeship really started in most
cases and we continued being apprentices
while we were making making a living
then we become journeyman we become
competent at what we do and the lucky
ones among us become master craftsmen so
let's stop think of his a stop thing of
history professors or CEOs as having one
kind of of success in the world and
people who are master craftsmen at being
cabinet makers as being another kind
they're all they're all doing the same
thing and recognizing that common
kinship in what we're striving to do I
think is absolutely essential in
combating what is becoming a very
poisonous kind of class division in this
country I've gone of stray from your
question but I wanted to say all that
thank you
you know that was very well said and I
think at the heart of it is what your
your trying to say there's no ability to
work and doing using your talents and
what what God has given you to put at
the service of yourselves your family
and fellow man and that's part of what
seems to be lost as we let government
take more and more of the civil society
over for us I want to pick on you and I
don't think you're gonna disagree with
me in your talk you said some of these
whole departments are entirely useless
and I think you would agree that many of
them are worse than that because they
crowd out innovation in the private
sector and they they disallow what we
don't see boss it was pointed out this
phenomenon that we don't see when
government does something is what would
have happened if private resources had
been redirected to their best ends just
to make that comment I think we have one
more question and that's a great segue
to my question because that's also about
education and it's about the role of the
for-profit education sector the Kipp
academies of the world and the Phoenix
universities of the world
what do you see they're clearly being
demonized by the federal government what
do you see as their role in the
evolution of the education system in
this country I'm gonna have to tell you
that I am having a hearing problem and I
didn't get the last part of that
question just to the last could you
repeat the last bit of that question
what what do you see as the future of
the for-profit sector the future of the
for-profit guess what I can actually be
optimistic for once this is one of the
few places I think that we are looking
at a set of market forces that are going
to transform education it's not going to
happen because the Congress votes for
different laws I think these are in
electable I'm indebted to a guy named
Peter teal who is the guy who invented
PayPal and it was an early investor in
facebook who's been quite involved in
this issue he's refering to higher
education now as a bubble in the same
sense the real estate was a bubble
and and we've had other kinds of tech
bubbles and so forth
in this sense more and more people are
beginning to realize that all this money
they're paying for higher education
isn't worth it their kids are not
getting a liberal education liberal in
the classic sense of the term so they
aren't coming out of college as educated
men and women but neither are they
learning how to make a living they are
accumulating huge student debts and so
on the one on the on the cost side you
have all sorts of reasons that a lot of
people are going to say you know what I
know it's hard to get a job interview
without a college education but I just
can't go this route on the other side
look what you have happening in terms of
the resources for conducting education
the information technology revolution
has revolutionized what can be done with
distance learning what you can do over
the internet the ways in which you can
obtain training that you need at far
lower costs than going to a residential
facility all of these things are growing
despite the lack of interest by the
government and encourage them and indeed
all the ways in which teachers unions
the rest of it impede them but all of
these are extremely powerful
they're extremely effective and I expect
10 years from now post-secondary
education is going to be radically
different from the way we see it now and
it's the information technology
revolution which will made it happen and
it's going to be great